remember remember the 5th of November
[Music]
be for Vendetta wait doesn't even [ __ ]
you in you're a person sorry yes I am a
thematic person so on the 5th of
November I just couldn't help myself so
V for Vendetta is the story of a man
known only as the letter V evey Hammond
played by my wife not really and Britain
which is ruled in this movie by a
totalitarian government what is a
totalitarian government you know Hitler
Stalin little guys and things are really
bad in this country in this movie we're
talking oppression murder censorship
people being hauled off in black bags to
die never to be seen again based on race
or sexual orientation and so v is set on
liberating this country by rallying the
people with words poetry and blowing up
Parliament with c4 not gonna lie that
would probably send a message tell you
the truth I always thought V looked
French you know like one of those huh Oh
types now there's a lot to like about V
for Vendetta I mean when you have a
movie that's all like fight for the
people power to the people liberate them
from the tyranny that oppresses them you
already have me intrigued
in a lot of ways Batman Begins took this
approach and the concept is when the
chips are down and oppression has
gripped the people into apathy you need
a big dramatic example just to shake
them out of it it's really not just
confined to movies that is how people
are now Hugo Weaving aka Agent Smith was
perfect as V I mean the guy's
intelligent sophisticated smart and
badass his methods can be a little
extreme that does not make him uncool he
has a zillion and a half lines that you
want to remember when watching this
movie all of which are taken from real
poetry that we have in the world but
it's like a best-of compilation in V for
Vendetta so have a pen while you're
watching it or Google now I've never
actually read the graphic novel but I
heard there are huge differences between
the graphic novel and the movie one of
which is in the graphic novel you don't
really know at least a good guy or if
he's just crazy you're not really
supposed to know in the movie he's
clearly the protagonist he's a good guy
and they changed some of the political
spectrums to make it I don't know more
relatable to we Americans which I hate
it when they do that I would like to
think that we're not so stupid that we
can't relate to a movie because it's
based on another country's politics I
hope anyway but it's still a good movie
now one main misconception is that V for
Vendetta is some sort of action movie it
does have a couple of action scenes in
it but all in all it's not it's a
political movie in which a
knife-wielding weirdo
Hiro is hell-bent on liberating his
country from tyranny you know simple but
what can I say
I do agree with the guy's views does
that make me crazy some people have told
me that V for Vendetta promotes
terrorism or some [ __ ] and promote
terrorism it promotes freedom like
William Wallace and [ __ ] but I would say
that V for Vendetta is awesome tacular
and yes I will start reviewing classic
movies that I actually don't like but
it's the 5th of November I mean how can
I resist but if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more and
click right here to see more as always
[Music]